one I can't believe it happened why
would you arrest a 10-year-old kid that
Mississippi woman's 10-year-old son was
arrested last year for the terrible
offense of urinating behind his mom's
car a judge recently sentenced him to 3
months probation but the family is
fighting back quantavius Ean was caught
peeing behind his mom's car while she
was in a meeting last August latan Ean
reprimanded her son but the cops
escalated the situation anyway five
police officers showed up to arrest the
10-year-old taken to a police station
and he even throw him inside a jail cell
quantavius was labeled a child in need
of supervision and a judge gave him a
harsh probation sentence even requiring
quantavius to agree to submit to drug
tests I think that it is unreasonable
that a 10-year-old would be arrested for
doing something I did as a child gr from
Mississippi Police have no business
arresting a third grader over a minor
indiscretion cops should protect their
communities from real threats and this
10-year-old certainly wasn't one